dude [ __ ] Ferguson and wrestle so
he's got both but what's up what's going
on with Tonetta I feel bad for a man
feel like they're leaving him in the
[ __ ] dust no no no no no no no no no
no yes him
no they know they they're very serious
about doing something with Tony Ferguson
Danny even said that he is most likely
nekton next in line for khabib 20
Ferguson look after you possess it man
[ __ ] yeah he does and after that
performance against Pettis like come on
man this is this is the time it's the
time to set him out he's so [ __ ]
tough he wants it to them I think to be
said him or just be nice man
Tony hasn't lost in what is it 12 fights
now how many fights is it 11 it's a
little bit strange I'll fight win streak
against guys like Edson Barboza Darcys
heavenly heavenly triangles him
Pettis Pettis gets an injury but
Thompson Josh Thompson Lando beat some
tough [ __ ] guys man Lando came at him
he had no training camp for that one do
you think that's an ex fight they make
though Lando is a talented guy man yeah
we caught him I mean he clipped him he
clipped him with that he does this head
kick out of the break um but he survived
that in one I mean dude Tony Ferguson is
a [ __ ] beast look at it was 3ho man
Josh Thompson monster Barbosa
monody just look at San Jose those of
ándara Hafele dos Anjos and Kevin Lee
and then Anthony Pettis in a row
those guys does not nearly get nearly
get the attention he deserves Ahad man
he's got a million followers now needs
more you know he should he should be
first of all I don't think he should
have been stripped cuz he got one time
doing USC press is doing something he
tripped over some wires it's a freak
accident it's just something that
happened you know to strip him because
of that like I don't know I think you be
Anthony
says 60% no more ID but he/she I've
she's looked better before the injury
obviously but him come back that fast
doing what he did isn't it's like even
dog crews like I don't know how the [ __ ]
he's doing this so I thought even as
good as he looked that slamming him at
his you know he's gonna be even better
in this next fight well I think Morris
Pettis look really good to you got to
give credit to Paris for sure clip Titus
clipped him and he had him hurt but Tony
figured out a way to hold on and survive
but he didn't look like he was missing a
beat to me he looked he looked very in
tune did I I hurt something that he
didn't spar for this is that true I'm
not too sure what he does with the
striking I'm never there when he trans
with the striking I have no idea to tell
you the truth oh you don't stay ok I'm
just doing with the ground no we do you
only do knows [ __ ] told me I've heard
that too but when he spars when we do
Jiu Jitsu we we definitely spar
situation we do situation right know
like straight up striking no 16-ounce
gloves man Donna is such a debate what a
crazy debate that is the tree own does
the same thing does he know sparring
here's a Spartan six years might not it
might not be a bad idea
Robbie Lawler took six years of sparring
to he did but then he became better when
he went to 1880 when he went to ATT and
started you know training with some
serious talent down there and dropped
down to 170 I would like know that that
the period of no sparring I think that
was the 85 period when he was at
Strikeforce well Chad Mendes took a
while off too cuz offs he got busted but
then he took time off and then he's
looking freakin pretty gnarly